right now the skies above you are pretty
empty but if electric vertical takeoff
and Landing or EV toll companies get
their way the skies could look a lot
more like this these companies envisage
a future where you and I can travel
directly across congested Urban cities
the problem is if the sky was suddenly
full of every single air taxi company in
development the airspace might not cope
as a surge of new traffic could
overwhelm current air traffic control
systems there's only one airspace you
can't create another Universe for
another airspace so now experts are
trying to find ways to integrate EV
tolls into our airspace without
disrupting existing flights if they
don't get it right air taxis may never
truly get off the ground so what does
the future look like let me show you
foreign I've come up to the roof of my
office here in London because it's
places kinda like this that air taxi
companies will want to take off and land
from companies like Joby Archer whisk
and others are pitch in the future where
you'd be able to request EV tolls on
demand much like you would an Uber you'd
head to your nearest Eevee to a landing
spot or verti port and after boarding
you'd be flown directly to your
destination verti Port skipping over all
of the congested traffic below and
saving lots of time for example Joby
says that a trip from downtown Manhattan
to JFK could take just seven minutes in
their EV toll versus a 49 minute drive
I'll just sending a push of the button
you can make these like really
convenient trips now if all of what I've
just described sounds a bit like a
helicopter you're kind of right there
are some key differences but in some
ways EV tiles are set to be like a
quieter electric version of a helicopter
operating under 3000 feet which is three
times the height of this thing and
that's why initially the FAA and the
civil aviation Authority here in the UK
are planning on treating them similarly
as low-flying low density traffic but as
their operations ramp up and their
density increases experts tell me that
won't be sustainable
to find out why I took a trip to the
epicenter of the UK's Air Traffic
Control gnats
Nats manages the UK's airspace by
interacting with aircraft that are
moving through areas of controlled
airspace see while the skies above your
head may look like a continuous wide
open space air traffic controllers see
things a little differently for them
it's actually a complex
three-dimensional map of different
regions of airspace some controlled some
not and each with its own set of rules
it's the job of air traffic controllers
like Fran to help aircraft safely
navigate through their airspace by
speaking to them if an aircraft wants to
fly in controlled airspace it has to do
certain things it has to tell us where
it wants to go what it wants to do what
levels it wants to do it and it has to
talk to us and have our permission to be
there but how it gets there will then
depend on how much other air traffic it
has to interact with along the way and
deconflicting those aircraft now even
though huge swathes of the US are
uncontrolled or class G airspace the
areas where air taxis are open to
operate are set to be within dense Urban
centers and airports which is often
controlled airspace where you do have to
contact air traffic control and while
some information can be shared digitally
every time we need to give an
instruction to a pilot that is what we
would consider safety critical so a
level change or a heading or a route
instruction we have to say it to the
pilot and the pilot has to read it back
now it could take years for a thriving
Air Taxi industry to emerge but if and
when it does air traffic controllers
could be facing hundreds even thousands
of EV tolls seeking guidance every day
is there a point in which you say sorry
we can't accept any more aircraft in
this airspace today because so we do
manage the number of aircraft that come
into the airspace and that's based on a
lot of different factors we still have
to talk to the pilots a lot and so
that's often one of our limiting factors
is how much you can actually speak okay
cool so how do you deal with that how do
you create an extra capacity for a
future influx of aircraft in an already
very busy airspace what we really
require are new technology and new ages
Elizabeth Chow is part of a team at Nats
that's looking at how to integrate EV
tolls we are looking at switching voice
communication into more digital forms of
communication the first step is to
digitize instructions given out by
people like Fran that digital
information could then be shared among
all airspace users so each aircraft
knows where the other is headed the next
step is to ensure these EV toll are
flying predictable paths by creating
virtual roads in the sky we already do
this for conventional aircraft and we're
thinking of adding more rocks into the
sky to integrate EV tiles for the air
taxis it means that instead of flying in
a straight line from A to B they may
have to join their nearest Road in the
sky but by mass sharing data and flying
along fixed routes potential conflicts
could be predicted and route changes
made far in advance creating more
capacity and then slowly building to
hang on a minute do we need active
control or do we Elevate the human to a
more supervisory role that step would be
vital to accommodate Air Taxi company's
plans to make their EV tolls uncrewed
the faa's next-gen team and NASA have
also been working on a similar plan
where efficient they plan on creating EV
toll corridors the aircraft are going to
fly a line segment that line segment is
defined the the whole method of how
we'll communicate those various
trajectories and incorporate them along
with other data that we may have in the
system is exactly what we've been
working on these corridors could also be
turned on and off based on the other
traffic in the area stay tuned though as
the FAA is expected to release its
updated plan for Ev tolls this summer so
when can we expect to see ev tolls
traveling along these roads in the sky
well we could be a few years away yet
while Elizabeth told me that the UK
expects to see ev tolls in its airspace
within the next five years Joby told me
that it could be over a decade until
they reach a density that we need to
create virtual corridors for them so at
that decade time frame when we start to
get congested or decade and a half we
need to have plans in place here's the
thing though it's not just our taxes the
airspace handlers are preparing for over
the past few years we've seen a huge
increase in everything from rocket
launchers to drone deliveries to
electric and hydrogen flights and as our
skies get busier it's forcing those who
manage them to create smarter ways to
handle that traffic we're really gearing
up in the FAA to move to what we call an
information-centric National airspace
environment and it's going to be shared
situational awareness to a whole range
of users very different from what we've
encountered today so while roads in the
sky for air taxis could be years away
the road to building them could help all
flights even today's run a little
smoother
[Music]
foreign